michel larive députés dans la 2e
circonscription de l'ariège la france
insoumise michel larive merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
ce plan de déconfinement du premier
ministre cole t-il à la réalité de votre
circonscription de l'ariège
malheureusement j'avais d'aujourd'hui au
moins est malheureusement parce que ce
qu'a dit monsieur le premier ministre
c'est que à partir de maintenant et
jusqu'à dorénavant ce sera pareil
qu'avant c'est à dire que déjà depuis le
départ depuis le début de ce confinement
nous départements éloignés mais je pense
que d'autres départements aussi avons
agi en responsabilité pour assurer la
protection des populations parce que
l'état était défaillant et il s'avère
qu'il continue à être défaillant puisque
il ya là aujourd'hui on le voit une
inversion du paradigme républicain la
république doit protéger ses citoyens et
là c'est l'inversé qui se passe
monsieur legendre monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le gendre nous disent
que le citoyen doit être responsable
il ira à l'école et travailler en
volontariat ça veut dire ça veut dire
que si diva de manière volontaire il est
donc responsable
et s'il est malade il est donc
responsable on nous dit qu'il y aura des
masques mais ce n'est pas l'état qui va
les fournir comme je vous le dis depuis
le début de cette crise ce sont les
collectivités territoriales les maires
et autres qui se sont débrouillés pour
protéger d'abord les soignants puis la
population là le premier ministre dit
qu'il va rembourser 50% du prix des
masques à partir d'aujourd'hui donc les
masques d'avant c'est pour les
collectivités territoriales et dans sa
grande bonté il va distribuer 5 millions
de masques aux 9 millions de pauvres de
notre pays
non il y a quand même un sacré problème
et s'il vous plaît la seule chose
positive aujourd'hui
vu l'état d'impréparation du dossier
c'est que peut-être que le 11 mai les
choses vont changer et que le daeu chine
n'aura peut-être pas lieu ou au moins il
aura lieu dans deux ans des manières
un peu plus sérieuse qu'aujourd'hui
parce que ce qui est dit aujourd'hui ne
nous amène pas à la sérénité
très très loin de là je vous le dis les
masques mais les tests 700000 texte soit
donc pour que la population dans son
ensemble soit testée il faudrait
quasiment deux ans donc non on a on a un
problème véritablement de protocoles et
en ces temps difficiles ce qu'il faut
lorsqu'on est top en responsabilité est
au pouvoir c'est rassurer les français
là ça n'est pas le cas du tout en a une
politique qui est de plus en plus
anxiogène
malgré les grandes annonces on se repose
sur les territoires alors que l'état
dans ces cas là est régalien sur la
protection des populations
très concrètement par exemple sur la
question des écoles les parents
s'apprêtaient finalement à renvoyer à
envoyer leurs enfants à l'école dès le
11 mais ça ne sera pas le cas ou en tout
cas en fonction des départements
cette mesure-là très précisément elle
vous rassure elle vous angoisse quel est
votre sentiment
elle nous rassure pas du tout comme je
vous le dis c'est sur la base du
volontariat donc ça veut dire que vous
rendez vous rendez vous compte de ce
qu'on demande aux parents de choisir lui
avec le peu de connaissances qu'il a de
la maladie du virus
des informations qui sont souvent
contradictoires entre monsieur blanc
caire monsieur ferry peu notre président
de la république tout ceci fait que lui
en responsabilité et l'enverra son
enfant sur la base du volontariat
ça veut dire que si jamais son enfant
contractent le virus ou un vecteur du
virus
c'est de sa responsabilité c'est quand
même fort de café peut donc partir de ce
moment là je crois qu'on attendait autre
chose de la parole d'edouard filet de ce
soir vous vous attendiez quoi par
exemple très précisément quels sont les
oublie que vous avez noté nous
atteindrons qu'elle nous dise qu'il a
pris effectivement connaissance de tout
ce qui se disait dans le pays ce n'est
pas le cas puisqu'il a ils passent et ne
consultent pas et qu'il qu'il a organisé
les choses ça n'est pas qu'elle n'a pas
organisé les choses
vous avez une date qui a été décidé par
monsieur le président de la république
le 11 mai et tout le monde s'est adapté
au tour alors qu'il fallait faire
inverse il fallait organiser planifier
même si on n'aime pas le mot est ensuite
posé des protocoles se mettre en
perspective et puis décider d'une date
là celle inverse emmène date et on doit
s'adapter et en plus cela on nous
indique que ceux qui devront s'adapter
ce seront les territoires pal et à
l'état arrivera en accompagnement celle
inverse qui doit se passer les douars de
l'état doit faire et les collectivités à
la rigueur arrivé en accompagnement
qu'il y ait des concertations avec le
local soit mais se défausser de sa
responsabilité sur le local ça n'est pas
possible et c'est anxiogène
alors c'est en tout cas toute
l'opposition qui est vent debout 1 ce
soir contre ce plan de déconfinement on
est loin de l'unité voulue par le chef
de l'état pour conclure cette unité elle
doit passer par ou faut désormais parler
coup tu parles écoute d'abord des gens
qui sont spécialistes de la chose
lorsque le comité scientifique nous
indique qu'il est extrêmement préférable
de repousser la rentrée scolaire en
septembre ni edouard philippe ni moi
sommes de grands patrons praticiens au
niveau de la médecine dont moi
personnellement j'aurais écouté le
conseil scientifique et puis sur les
territoires il ya eu des remontées ti on
dit qu'il n'y avait pas de protocole
établi et que le flou n'était pas
souhaitable et le flou et est anxiogène
chaque corporation chaque métier
risquent de ne pas reprendre parce qu'il
n'a pas de protocole établit donc si
vous voulez l'état s'est défaussé non
seulement sur les collectivités mais
puis ensuite après sur les corporations
alors il va il va y avoir autant de
métiers qu'il y aura deux protocoles
aucune harmonisation et les masques
c'est quand même formidable qu'en grèce
le masque est offert avec le journal au
portugal on vous le mets dans les boîtes
aux lettres avec une notice et en france
il faudra de l'acheter 5 voire 7 euros
ça c'est formidable alors michel larive
ou rester avec nous on va écouter
quelques français qui sont
partager un sur ce déconfinement prévenu
prévue le 11 mai prochain on les écoute
et jeannin a marre de rester chez eux
les commerçants appareils sont en train
de perdre de l'argent il faut absolument
qu'on déconfite assez rapidement parce
qu'il va y avoir un un énorme problème
économique du 2 juillet ce qui sont à
l'école et ils sont 40 par classe ils
sont 2000 dans son école dans une cour
de récréation j'étais pas comment ils
vont faire et donc je suis très inquiète
non seulement pour les vagues ont
également surtout pour les enfants un
problème à nous dès qu'on fume trop tôt
c'est à dire qu'il ya encore trop de
risque n'est pas assez de pourcentage de
la population qui étaient atteints par
le virus qu'ils s'y soient immunisés
donc partir de ce moment là je pense que
même s'il arrive un peu trop tôt de
toute manière il ya de fortes chances en
fait qu'il ya un deuxième continent par
la suite qui se rajoutent et place au
direct on va tout de suite prendre la
direction de l'assemblée nationale où le
débat se poursuit autour du plan de
déconfinement présenter 1,27 après midi
par edouard philippe on va écouter eric
ciotti député les républicains selon des
instructions données par votre
gouvernement l'intransigeance ailleurs
faible avec les forts et fort avec les
faibles
voilà ce qu'ont ressenti beaucoup de
français nous vous mettons en garde
contre ces menaces
or vous n'avez pas dit un mot monsieur
le premier ministre pas un seul mot nous
vous demandons de réouvrir les tribunaux
de réouvrir les centres de rétention
administrative pour accueillir les
clandestins les plus dangereux
nous vous demandons de stopper les
libérations de détenus certains
radicaliser à ce rythme il y en aura 20
mille de moins offrait enfin aux
policiers aux gendarmes
véritable oubliés de la république et
nous le devons là aussi considération et
respect les moyens qu'ils méritent et
qui ment primes et paiement des heures
supplémentaires
d'autres crises viendront sans doute
peut-être plus grave encore la meilleure
arme face à ces crises c'est un état
fort et respecté réarmer enfin l'état
dans cette crise c'est avec des vies
humaines que notre peuple a soldé ses
erreurs et ses retards
comme l'écrivait déjà en 1940 le général
de gaulle or face à cette étrange
défaite
nous sommes toujours pas prêt c'est pour
cela monsieur le premier ministre que je
n'approuverait pas votre plan monsieur
le député la parole est à monsieur hervé
saulignac du coup voilà eric ciotti
député les républicains qui vient de
s'exprimer en direct de l'assemblée
nationale je vous le rappelle à un débat
est en train de suivre les annonces du
premier ministre
obama y revenir tout de suite avec
michel larive il est avec nous il est
député dans la 2e circonscription de
l'ariège la france insoumise michel
larive on vient d'entendre eric ciotti
des républicains dire d'autres crises
viendront après cette crise sanitaire
vous rejoignez ce constat je ne sais pas
que d'autres crises arrivent derrière
cette crise sanitaire mais
malheureusement j'ai peur qu'ils n'aient
pas tort parce que ce que nous voyons
aujourd'hui c'est que si vous voulez une
unité nationale il faut qu'une autorité
gouvernementale existait l'autorité elle
ne devait être basée que sur la
confiance du peuple et le discours qu'on
vient d'entendre d'edouard philippe ne
donne pas confiance pose un grand grand
problème est pas encore plus
d'interrogations qu'avant son discours
donc là nous avons un réel problème
effectivement entendu également des
français à réagir au micro de rtl france
on a senti l'inquiétude une certaine
angoisse finalement à reprendre une vie
après le 11 mai une vie le plus normale
possible vous comprenez cette inquiétude
des français
oui tout à fait oui tout à fait le
l'objectif de tout le monde que ce soit
dans l'hémicycle où toute la population
française c'est de pouvoir être des
confiné je crois que c'est ça l'objectif
de tout le monde mais il faut le faire
en connaissance de cause il faut
préparer ce déconfinement il faut avoir
les moyens d'offrir un masque à toute la
population
gratuitement il faut pouvoir assurer des
protocoles qui permettent aux enfants de
manger dans la cantine de suivre des
cours dans en toute sécurité il faut que
les soignants les les enseignants les
ouvriers qui vont participer à cette
relance économique soit protégé
en tous les cas de figure voilà ce qu on
entend ce qu'on attend d'un gouvernement
responsable en responsabilité et doit à
un moment donné prendre des décisions
effectives comme le disait d'ailleurs
monsieur ciotti mais comme le disait
surtout monsieur mélenchon c'est que ce
gouvernement droit on attend de lui
qu'il prenne des responsabilités et
qu'il donne un cap en connaissance de
cause et ça n'est pas le cas on est là
dans un cas où ce gouvernement nous dit
voilà chaque quart sera différent on
verra au cas par cas
c'est à dire que moi en ariège j'aurai
une méthode de déconfinement qui sera
sûrement différente de celle de l'aude
de la haute-garonne et chacun verra
comment ça va se passer dans sa localité
alors ce choix tous les parents
d'enfants se disent est ce que je vais
envoyer mais mon enfant à l'école
dans ces conditions maintenant que tout
le monde veut être d'un confus mais je
le comprends amplement parce que moi je
le souhaite le premier alors la question
des masques à que vous venez d'aborder
aussi la question de ces fameux tests si
fortement réclamée pendant des semaines
par la population et les professionnels
ils seront enfin pratiquer en masse à
presles déconfinement je vous propose
michel larive d'écouter le premier
ministre edouard philippe
nous nous sommes fixé l'objectif de
réaliser au moins 700 mille tests
virologiques par semaine au 11 mai
pourquoi cette envie parce que le
conseil scientifique nous dit à ce stade
que les modèles épidémiologiques prévoit
entre 1000 et 3000 cas nouveaux chaque
jour à partir du 11 mai parce qu'à
chaque à nouveau correspondra en moyenne
le test d'au moins 20 à 25 personnes
l'ayant croisé dans les jours précédents
3000 x 25 x 7
cela donne 525 milles test par semaine
sept cent mille nous donne la marge qui
nous permettra en plus des tests des
chaînes de contamination que je viens de
décrire de mettre en oeuvre des
campagnes de dépistage comme nous
l'avons déjà engagés pour les ehpad
notamment nous avons engagé la
mobilisation conjointe des laboratoires
publics et privés qui peuvent
aujourd'hui montée en charge
très rapidement en termes de capacité
cette mobilisation permettra de garantir
sur tout le territoire un accès de
proximité aux prélèvements nous allons
enfin faire passer à 100% la prise en
charge de cette ne ces tests pardon par
l'assurance maladie
alors michel larive la perspective de
700 mille tests par semaine dans votre
circonscription est ce que vous êtes
prêts à réaliser ces tests est ce que
vous êtes déjà organisé alors nous avons
la chance en ariège de n'avoir eu que
malheureusement deux décès sont dus
locaux vides et donc très peu demi n'a
pas fortement frappé dans notre
département
mais si l'on regarde le calcul de
monsieur edouard philippe
il a de quoi tester des gens qui vont
être déclarées apparemment porteurs du
virus et l'entourage milne les moyens
que de faire ceci il n'aura pas les
moyens de faire ce qu'il a dit dans les
ehpad ou ailleurs parce que moi aussi je
fais un tout petit peu de mathématiques
il en a fait tout à l'heure dans
l'assemblée sept cent mille sept cent
mille nous avons 67 millions d'individus
dans le demeurer population est de 67
millions d'habitants donc en gros à la
louche comme ça ça fait à peu près un
peu moins de deux ans pour pouvoir
tester tout le monde l'envié est ce que
je vais dire ça veut dire qu'à un moment
donné
ceci ne suffit pas comme ça a été
précisé ensuite effectivement qu'il va
falloir s'organiser localement mais on
attend une direction une aide comprenez
on attend une institution forte parce
qu'il est là dans des cas de crise
énorme comme celle-là il a évoqué la
première guerre mondiale
on lui a répondu sur ce sujet nous
sommes dans des crises similaires
quelque part bien que nous ne soyons pas
en guerre c'est une épine amis nous ne
sommes pas en guerre contre un autre
peuple contre quelqu'un d'autre c'est
une épidémie mais
il faut un état fort c'est à dire qu'un
état qui a une parole forte et à partir
de ce moment-là peut-être qu'il
réenclenche sera un processus de
confiance et que les choses pourront se
faire j'allais dire quasiment
d'elle-même la population participera à
cet élan là en l'occurrence nous n'avons
pas un état fort nous avons un état qui
se repose et qui se défausse de sa
responsabilité et tout à l'heure
j'entendais monsieur le jambes qui
parlait de responsabilité individuelle
rendez vous compte du poids il fonde
posés sur chaque citoyenne et citoyen de
deux semaines bien sûr que la population
est en responsabilité
bien sûr que lorsque quelqu'un est
touché par le coup vide il le dit bien
sûr que le confinement est bien fait
dans la majeure partie des cas donc ça
on n'a pas besoin de le dire aux
français ce qu'on a besoin maintenant ce
que la france a besoin ce que la
population française a besoin de savoir
c'est qu'il ya un pilote dans l'avion
merhari demande
merci beaucoup michel larive d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes député de la 2e
circonscription de l'ariège